all right Canadians yes I haven't seen
that placard in like a while yes or no
the et yeah yeah I just bring it just
because I would to Keshia chante et
Canada is home yeah I bring it so people
can see that I'm Canadian and it changes
the tone of the room you know it's great
for better it just gives a nicer so to
Canadians playing criminals and 21
bridges what was it like you stretch
right there all right
it was crazy Ord about it yes hearts am
i right yeah no it was awesome I mean
and I just keep saying how excited I was
the first time I I read this script you
know have to chatter called me and
pitched it to me I was like man this is
like a movie I've been dying to make a
lot of my favorite films high high
action films with you look at heat or
Reservoir Dogs or Good Fellas you know
it just felt like we were stepping into
something that could be really really
exciting what is the biggest
misconception about Canadians in
Hollywood are there any maybe that would
be nice I mean that's worldwide not just
in the Hollywood Bowl yeah nothing wrong
with that either okay pretty good one I
have yeah
not a misconception it's pretty true I
like the kid we're pretty we're pretty
nice to a fault really
yeah I apologize for everything yeah
yeah awesome
so great thank you you play gambit as a
superhero Chadwick black panther um
Siena played Baroness mmm guys all
played superheroes except you yeah um
well you know what I've been thinking
about it yeah
me and about for quite some time
and spider-man here I come I am ready
well to be spider-man mmm how cool it
would it be if like Michael just I
wasn't you from gangs in New York like
that'd be what would be your superpower
not spider-man but like if you could
pick one um cliche question I think just
like I would have the power to to just
like disappear yeah you know just like
just get out of there anytime I needed
to get out I think that'd be that's fair
be kind of cool give me that yeah you
guys are having a great chat it's good
to see you it's good see you working on
21 bridges with Chadwick with Siena it's
a great cast JK yeah yeah yeah what was
the best part of you guys getting
together for this was there a moment
while filming that was this is the thing
it's like there in the wake of our
violence in what we do in the film and
so it's that was how we filmed as well
so it was just like sometimes we would
see them as we're leaving you don't get
to drink our I'm seen good luck with
that you know and it's like we're kind
of go by each other to the trailers but
it wasn't a whole lot of interaction
yeah okay so you guys didn't hang out
period yeah that's great guys great yeah
um what are your plans for Christmas are
you going back to Canada
either you I'm betting on mecklen I will
yeah I'm gonna go full Griswold on my
house with lights and everything else
too so I can't wait to do that okay yeah
eggnog what are you gonna do oh I'm
going back to Canada no no all right
we'll see you boys I'll be there
hopefully it's a white one